for two years now Teresa made his
promise that breaks it means breaks it
that Britain's taking back control of
laws money and borders what we've seen
is indecision infighting resignations
and rebellion so what if this headline
was true when Britain does leave the
European Union without a deal how would
that affect everybody in Britain after
all this is an island nation reliance on
the flow of trade in and out of the
country so even if we continue to get
off flours tariff free from Holland
because they guarantee that customs
officials on the other side of the
channel will do likewise for our Goods
and our services and that ultimately is
the crux of the matter theoretically
life could just carry on as it has done
in the past but there's no domestic
legal obligation for it to do so if we
leave the EU without any kind of a deal
that means lots of uncertainty which is
why businesses are likely to cut back on
investment and why the pound is likely
to take another tumble with implications
for everything we buy no deal poses a
huge challenge to the delivery of fresh
medicines to hospitals and pharmacists
particularly time and temperature
sensitive products like insulin crucial
to the daily lives of more than 400,000
British diabetics including the Prime
Minister but almost all of it is
manufactured and imported from Europe
it's among the 75 million medicines that
pass back and forth from the continent
every month and why ministers are
planning to stockpile to make sure
no-one goes short what if you're one of
the 1.2 million UK nationals living
working or studying on the other side of
the channel or one of the three million
EU citizens in the UK will you be able
to continue a lot of work had gone into
guaranteeing reciprocal rights for EU
and UK citizens but with no deal it'll
be up to individual countries to
negotiate their positions don't worry
we're not going to have mass
deportations but people could have to
get visas to travel permits to work and
could face increased bureaucracy to stay
on and there's lots of worry about
access to areas like health care and
benefits this is a reality yet but
people are being warned life could get
more complicated no deal is better than
a bad deal was the Prime Minister's
mantra before the plans for stockpiles
not just for medicines but for food too
before the plans to turn a 13-mile
stretch of the m20 into a giant lorry
park for 2,000 vehicles before the plans
of the customs department essentially
not to enforce border checks in order to
keep traffic flowing whilst per Exeter's
argue that all this is the same old
scare stories that there amidst that no
deal could mean no forty billion pound
brexit bill negotiators don't want no
deal but by defaults or even by
accidents it could be where we're
heading